completely need
he is also strong
he
[Music]
you can access
so me too
rotrand north to the president arrived
by the guys not by chance do the
last
some
strong relationship and I believe
every time
I follow
the spindles further
it's good
mr has often played also
joy
promeo are rare over the week here
I even have a
gfr
the mouth of the pass
it pulls I tell myself to count near
the other side
but it is thanks to my passion
for criticism it is not  not finished
or not
i never know when a woman live
we
voluntarily
sorry
yeah
leaving
on a leash and no i
would like to me
mamma mia
how
gold is allowed by the code
[Music]
he
excuse me
apparently he
dams
loud
oh
no so really this cat
so it is possible
yes
it
how
[Music]
days
it
m
when
lock
[Music]
and there that it arrives not one
and
we arrived so that the base
I still want
marco
yes I hear you
[Music]
m
antibes l'ava  it was not
[Music]
there
hello comes out
no
if I sing
here
to resist
it was not going to harm you
but who
enjoy it
good weather
and
we
no
it is
ex
made to turn
baj
we come on
to be able otherwise heavier
products
yes
how
e
the others don't seem to have the
title
there's the biker who normally arrives
with a witness I don't have an ordinary soul
[Music]
I'm going
torisk
you don't see boris the
bikers there  rule of
art
we
no not for now but do
n't hear foot no no if they're coming they're
coming they're coming they're coming it's
good if I have a witness
hello that you'll agree for you
were a child
asoap do
n't pronounce
if we get to the story of the 50
mg/l perfume told
m
you have
I am with will
arrive exploded this morning es5 come hello
hello avoid you in place good
that's it in front of the restaurant the good
wheel to replace the film  is really
helped all in the game so we at first i
was doing m  oi yes I understood yes yes
I understood I understood
[Music]
access by the house told month of the kickoff
a very strong explosion for
the series b with a glass in fact on
what happened  it's that my goal I
thought it's to make up for it since
all that hasn't been done
the spirit of going out to me I'm trying to
concern us suicide bombing compared to
another suddenly when I have  I saw afterwards through the
window that it was the bakery there
I said to myself c
me I did not see
ah yes
young woman would have safety gifts from
the bakery
no according to me I saw
the bourgeois site repacking people
who is a  word on the senses
it's by you've seen worse are they
armed
expected
yes ok that's
m
yes indeed I'm with
ibra slipped dreaming this morning with
this strong expression withdrawal will aim to
jump far so here we go seeing
the mergers they  were these forces is
really very strong
I have already I have already heard abroad
speaking experts  it's not like
that we wear at the beginning that it was
really forced
started apart and after in our a
sudden outing all the life who excuse nickname the
window of your apartment life
exactly in addition it is  a large
window before its 18 that's a bit like that so
far suddenly well it's only afterwards when I saw
the doubt ball there I said to myself I have
a question what did you do
then questions  because
you saw in the street
a scene of chaos before a scene of
chaos
but not the only one the ground below I see
a scene of chaos passing by the gardens and
what did
you see me d
me I didn't  saw the injured we
accompany saw me I was above all had
to combine but it is more focused
on the bakery and on the smoke the
on the 110 per year
cockroaches from when to
spy on them the
dogs lost our pages on
the environment at  about ten minutes
after something like that a lot we
went out hadn't e  ncore firefighters from
the police forces so
I remember we wanted to
leave the street we took refuge there a
little bit in a café and that's where
we saw the firefighters the police and so on
reader is what  you have had
damage in
spite of in your apartment with
material damage or as long as we are
alive and as long as we are well we are in good
health the descent and of the kind
orapi people
you have seen neighbors is what
some have  had mistakes
of course of course we had the view of the
neighbors we didn't know what it was we
even had the encounter it is permissible
to habitat cost from 5 next door she
announced that it is a tremor father
each of the month syntheses  basically it's that
it's in the meantime
I said to myself it's an advantage not to
go out because if I go out and there is
possibly something these showers
better at home in case
you have any  still market the
accomplices no no no no
I thought about that for two minutes
and fo  nd the participants did not
say did mid-January
vonn who exploded to your
knowledge did you have any finances at all
because I often have them there to
buy
a lanyard of his own as of Monday
I  it's not a bakery it's
really a
place so that's why I spent
the
girls moreover it's as much as its own the
base that's really a nice
bakery that's I  I didn't think that
this testimony from one of the first
testimonies is really about this
explosion and realism
how
we will try to
tell you too
here I am going to 10 discarded
and you do
n't be sorry
so there it's better Nantes
Gaza strip
it must be seen  do it
[Music]
no I'm going to do it we're going to say lausanne
it's 11 a.m. in a three-star hotel
expected
and then
no I haven't seen a single one this morning
he's
here
well listen I wasn't born like that
we know
I saw make-ups of power I
don't know how to defend you
canvas in hlm years regularly removed  ed
the songs reread
the bloody Thursday that a helicopter I was
starting
I
ok we're going to do the 11 o'clock
easy
about 500 kg penicaud to investigate
the main gastric
no
because
I
[Music]
so then
no but
poutine
obviously
thank you
and
we
were in  phase i
woke up by the explosion
onfire
[Music]
i do this after i didn't have to you
cornered
ahah
i'm going to you
[Music]
no
i
oh
[Music]
yes  we are about a hundred meters
from the scene of the disaster there high place
this explosion a little before 9 o'clock in the
morning the firefighters are still in
intervention we saw a few
moments ago an ambulance vehicle leaving the
old people there or not
and we are talking  30 years of staying
in absolute emergency the facts took
place a little before 9 a.m. there was
first a fire in a
langeree on this street very quickly in the
heart of paris and then
a very strong explosion and in  quite a lot of
damage to
the building and the same buildings
at intermission the moment we
talk to a couple who live
just opposite this bakery they were
woken up a little after 9 a.m. by
this explosion
of the windows which are  fallen in their homes there
are many witnesses now everything is
starting to tell the scene visibly
gas alert had been given a little
before
explosions and therefore we are
really not moving to make
a quality of a fire 2
accidental to order as  I was
the intervention of the firefighters is
still a little earlier in the morning
a helicopter and
you will present to hoist above
this street for your turn you are well helped by
the firefighters on the spot but also
by the civil security personnel that  'we
saw the attachment to values the banke
s went to Chinese a little earli
r in the morning to undou
tedly clear your fruits and evacuate the wound
d after
this strong explosion which
surprised everyone
this morning in the heart of paris
the scenes obviously
there are a few sessions
or people who were
leaving the place
the young woman in slippers with a
world proposed in a hurry on her
shoulders was in the process of  leave
very shocked supported by a lady a little
more at jesse mariveraine
section maybe someone who was in a
hotel and this neighborhood seems difficult
to tell the students
[Music]
the abraham potato
with
moore
not sure
there
in what i  I've already managed to see it
I ask for
my time naked it's
hu
wendy -
fitch unemployment in six months
you can see
the rest well
how
do you like I pass you the matisse de sécu
that
and
so I'm writing to you intervene well
with which one lasts
suffering
I am unfortunately
he
three biggest
sorry
ok
really
for me
the soul
yes indeed since this
intervention is still in
khoury sic
the explosion has
risen very very strongly as if I
remember in fact  and a hundred meters
from the blues
of the cissé maybe half an
hour after this explosion
there were still a lot
of people we arrived in
shock listen for example
and to question him
a little later
I can't hear well  beautiful
then yes I'm
ok ok we come back to me and that I
finish
the
men 1
ap
it's a
lot
a bit stupid
that you [Music] don't see you
anyway
but speaking
the emotion pass hello
it's the intervention remains in progress
I  going to go back because they see
how I heard
yesterday probably because the firefighters
this need to continue to secure the
place if we are as far away
his furniture daughter who ruled out
before 9 o'clock it's simply
at the maximum because  there is always a
risk
the framework
is confirmed this opportunity that there
are other exhibitors of the cac
obviously we are then situation with a
lot of attention
there are quite a lot of injuries at
least twenty and some are
very serious d  ifdifficulties
we are talking about
leaving in an absolute emergency
good
I am handing over to the iss
I don't know if you can hear me in the control room
I am going to hand over and 1
day
but that's how it is
no
make the French
well seen
henry
I'm looking squarely at the
canvas the family be
careful please it's not these
people are running
under sail and human
I made a big
none
le parigot
[Music]
I
top
thank you
there
more
m
[Music]
for the groups
I  don't know
in europe
[Music]
during the a
lot have nothing to do
with people who have to pay
juniors
suite
but not that
[Music]
it's okay but I want
all that  never go
these are 30
dark
[Music]
what
mj
the day before
I
saffron that my dress
not
there
[Music]